most of us have held at least one
soul-sucking job in our lives luckily
there's always the option of quitting
movie stars rarely have that option
bailing for them is more complicated
than simply leaving there are potential
lawsuits and almost always big financial
penalties all of which is why actors
usually end up toughing it out still
some actors get pushed to the breaking
point and come just short of actually
quitting even for some movies that are
regarded as classics today here are
actors who threaten to quit their most
famous role Wayne's World was filmed on
a relatively modest budget but is still
the only movie inspired by a Saturday
Night Live skit that's grossed over 100
million dollars Mike Meyers had come up
with the concept as a preteen debuted on
a Canadian variety show and perfected it
on SNL so the character was clearly dear
to Meyers his heart one famous scene
where Wayne and his friends are belting
out Queen's Bohemian Rhapsody in an AMC
Pacer was even written as no Maj to his
teenage years good cop he felt the song
was inherently comedic and loved the
thought of living out his memories of
head-banging during the instrumental
break in singing along but director
Penelope Spheeris had different ideas
the operatic tune seemed like an odd pic
to her so she suggested a different song
instead Meyers put his foot down and
threatened to quit if Queen was cut in
the end Myers won the scene became
iconic and bohemian rhapsody' returned
to the Billboard charts nearly 20 years
after its debut
How the Grinch Stole Christmas might
have been painful to watch but it was
even more painful for Jim Carrey to act
in the elaborate Grinch costume he wore
was made of itchy green yak hair
extensive facial prosthetics and yellow
contacts that appeared as big as
frisbees and reportedly felt like knives
in the eye the first day on the set of
the Grinch
carries makeup took a full eight and a
half hours to apply after he went back
to his trailer Carrey kicked a hole in
the wall and told director Ron Howard he
couldn't do the movie in an interview on
the Graham Norton Show he had harsh
words for the experience when I did the
Grinch I was literally the makeup was
like being buried alive every day
the first day was eight and a half hours
Carrey was only persuaded to stay when
the production hired someone who trained
CIA operatives to withstand torture to
assist Carrey in dealing with the daily
ordeal the key lesson was in pain
deferment and the actor often punched
himself in the leg if he was having a
particularly hard time Carrey remembers
the hundred days spent in the costume as
a real lesson in Zen it's amazing what
humans can endure in the end it seems
the torture was well worth it The Grinch
earned more than 345 million dollars in
worldwide box office sales making it the
second highest-grossing Christmas movie
of all time Emma Watson landed the role
of Hermione Granger and Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone at age 9 and
quickly became a fan favorite for her
layered portrayal of the character but
when Watson's contract came up for
renewal as the fifth installment of the
series was being shot rumors swirled
that she was ready to quit the problem
starring in the Harry Potter films
wasn't going to leave Watson time for a
college education had a real fight on my
hands to ensure that I was able to go to
university and I was able to sit my
a-levels the original schedule wouldn't
have left time for Watson to do any of
that and she was willing to quit over
the matter luckily the studio reworked
the shoot to accommodate Watson's
educational aspirations fast-forward to
the happy ending she continued to play
the beloved character in the final films
and earned a degree in English
literature from Brown University
[Music]
plan your carts pathetic we've got final
exams coming up soon Brad Pitt is known
for being an affable charismatic guy but
one look at him an interview with the
vampire and you can see he's not his
normal self when an Entertainment Weekly
reporter mentioned that he looked
miserable in the film Pitt replied I am
miserable six months in the [ __ ] dark
contact lenses the makeup
it seems Pitt signed on to play Louie
because he was intrigued by the
character's journey of self-discovery
unfortunately when he got the actual
script two weeks before filming started
everything he loved about Louie had been
cut now his role was basically to sit
back and watch Lestat played by Tom
Cruise one day during filming Pitt
decided he was done he called the
producer said he couldn't do it anymore
and asked how much it would cost him to
get out the answer was a cool 40 million
dollars unsurprisingly Pitt stayed on
and his character is best remembered as
giving Kirsten Dunst her first kiss
unfortunately it was about as pleasant
for her as the filming was for Pitt you
had a scream kiss with Brad Pitt yeah I
were 11 I did although I thought it was
disgusting it was like I was 11
The Fast and Furious franchise has
spawned a slew of sequels earned
billions of dollars and launched the
careers of the original Pictures
ensemble cast including Michelle
Rodriguez but Rodriguez's portrayal of
streetwise racer Letty Ortiz was almost
a non-starter
it seems Rodriguez signed on despite
having a major beef with her character's
story arc having only worked on a single
film before she was used to working out
character motivations on set but when
Rodriguez mentioned she didn't think it
was realistic for Letty to be caught in
a cheesy love triangle producers were
having none of it
Rodriguez cried threatened to quit and
begged the production not to sue her
when she left luckily with the support
of co-star Vin Diesel the script was
eventually changed in Rodriguez's
Hollywood dream and portrayal of Letty
Ortiz live to fight another day
[Music]
Jessica Alba's performance as Sue Storm
and Fantastic Four rise of the Silver
Surfer might have earned her a Razzie
nomination for worst actress but that
may not have been entirely her fault
according to alba director Tim story
complained that her appearance in an
emotional scene looked too real and
painful telling her to cry pretty the
experience was so traumatizing that Alba
considered quitting altogether in a
later interview Alba said I hated it I
really hated it so I just said it I
don't care about this business anymore
Alba didn't quit the role but afterwards
she pivoted for being an a-list actress
to founding the honest company a line of
beauty products The Shining is an
undisputed horror classic unfortunately
while millions of fans have delighted in
rewatching the film there's at least one
person who wasn't exactly happy with the
film Shelley Duvall who played Wendy
Torrance Duvall once characterized
working with the famed director as
almost unbearable and excruciating in an
interview with film critic Roger Ebert
in Stanley Kubrick a life in pictures
Jack Nicholson recall the time when
Kubrick forced Duvall to film a
particularly grueling scene 127 times
[Music]
all those takes took their toll Duvall
was dehydrated from crying so much and
clumps of hair fell out of her head
there are even hints that she considered
quitting due to health concerns in the
book The Compleat Kubrick Duvall States
I was really in and out of ill health
because the stress of the role was so
great it's the most difficult role I've
ever had to play even before legendary
comedian Lily Tomlin signed on to play
violet Newstead in nine-to-five she had
her doubts Jane Fonda who co-produced
the cult classic spent the better part
of a year convincing Tomlin to come on
board Tomlin told people I didn't want
to do a cheap comedy I was looking for
something more serious after she signed
on Tomlin caught a glimpse of her
performance in a fantasy scene where she
was acting with as yet non-existent
cartoon birds and thought she was
horrible in it
[Music]
thank you she promptly called the
producer offered to give her salary back
and beg to be let go
luckily Tomlin caught more footage from
later scenes and decided to stay on